talk to like Thug's character because
everybody I know just says he's just the
greatest guy he's the most generous guy
[ __ ] the most solid [ __ ] [ __ ] one of
the most solid [ __ ] you're gonna ever
meet in life if I'm saying that it's
crazy like he just so smart I heard that
[ __ ] like people would think like this
were one of the things that really stood
out to me about the like not [ __ ] the
fact that he a genuine [ __ ] everybody
that no Thug know that everybody that no
Thug know he care about everybody around
you just how smart he is musically and
how you try to help other people that
[ __ ] told me he said [ __ ] think like
oh what I'm doing y'all this [ __ ]
tripping you know it's weird [ __ ] but
who the [ __ ] gonna be the Rick James of
this generation we don't have said that
yeah I said damn slide that's you that
[ __ ] you know what I'm saying like the
prince or the free the print he said
both of them he said Prince Henry James
like who's the Andre 3000 of this
already being that [ __ ] though yeah and
all the [ __ ]
a gangster you know what I'm saying a
[ __ ] that's don't buy gangster what I
mean is stand on 10 and stand on what
you believe in and empower the people
around you and and be 100 completely
yourself no matter what nobody say and
ain't nobody gonna ain't nobody gonna
ever walk up to Thug and say I don't
like how you did this no
so what I mean by that is when he said
that bro it it threw me out it gave me a
whole another different like outlook on
him like nah this [ __ ] he right is a
different [ __ ] he's serious this the
type of [ __ ] that's like going to
change Generations you know what I'm
saying slime just a genuine [ __ ] and at
all every song I got with him he told me
to get on I promise the song I put out
on swervo the the [ __ ] we got on the
album other [ __ ] I ain't never since
Thug a record ever he always like huh
jump on this you can have it he told you
could have this [ __ ]
we had snapdog on the show and he was
like yeah I was I've been hanging out
with Doug the last couple years and he
noticed I would need glasses all right
squint yeah yeah no I was with him when
he did it when I was always all together
in the studio he snapped through he was
like Snap when he got his ass surgery
the next day
Doug was like yeah yeah that's crazy
that's so crazy we was together I
literally we was in the studio together
that was around the same time we did
brief slow this on how crazy is that
though he sent snap to go get his ass
surgery because he saw him squinting
that's a great [ __ ] bro it's not no
[ __ ] nobody's doing that who the [ __ ]
finna see you squint and say man you
good [ __ ] paid for his ass surgery bro
I swear to God he's in the studio we was
all together me and snap did a song that
day and me and Thug did a song that day
and the next morning snap went and got
his eye surgery [ __ ] I was there and
Thug covered it I was there that shit's
so crazy
and I'm just like yo that's some High
character [ __ ] a [ __ ] solid that dude's
not signed to him you know what I mean
he's just the right [ __ ] huh yeah what
you need you good if I'm saying like
that's real bro that's a real [ __ ] bro
you feel me like even watching the
untrapped [ __ ] with baby that [ __ ] ain't
no game bro [ __ ] get him whatever he
gave baby whatever the [ __ ] he wanted to
go rap you feel me the same that's just
being a good-hearted [ __ ] you know what
I'm saying if you able to do it it ain't
hurting him and you think that [ __ ]
don't hurt though to go get a [ __ ] this
or give [ __ ] some shine if I'm saying
it don't you know and I feel like as a
people that's why we supposed to be even
more adamant and Advocate about making
sure that that man and his kids is
protected by all costs whatever it is
you know what I'm saying whatever why he
go whatever whatever happens happens
whatever he's making sure he's good and
straight by any means you know what I'm
saying like
I talked to like Dolly his sister and
she like that yeah whatever slam me good
if I'm saying [ __ ] like that but at the
end of the day and I understand that
they're not gonna let nobody really in
for real you know what I'm saying
because of course so I gotta do is a
serious situation yeah you just gotta
really pray that he overcome that [ __ ]
and just embrace it Whatever by any
means anything that anybody ever called
me on behalf of the gun or any [ __ ] I
[ __ ] with I promise you I'm hands on
immediately you could call me and
whatever I'm gonna make a way to do it
because I understand it if I'm saying
whatever any [ __ ] I [ __ ] with whether
it's somebody this big or this big I
promise if it's anything I could do to
help I'm gonna do it